it's not easy to get to pakistan's zara
booty district
few people know their way around the
rough terrain
and for years most of the country was
unaware of the community's struggle
hundreds of people including children
have lost their limbs
because of explosive devices hidden in
the dry land
from a years-long conflict
now for the first time in years many are
walking again
on their own a local charity is giving
artificial limbs to more than a hundred
people
galib hussein is one of them he was 13
when he lost his legs 12 years ago
i took my goats and sheep to the
mountains that day but i didn't know
there were explosive devices in the area
suddenly there was a huge blast and i
lost my legs my parents are very poor
so they couldn't afford any treatment
i've had to stay home for the last 12
years
the bombs were left behind from a
conflict between pakistani forces and
the ballot liberation army
the fight goes back decades the
separatist group wants autonomy for the
region
explosives were placed in the ground
through the years but is mostly poor and
marginalized people
who've suffered the consequences many
have died
others left disabled the worst part was
this is too far off and the people are
too poor they're like hundreds more
patients who came up today
they wanted to see legs as you saw today
those people who are running around this
you know they must have
have influence on other people and they
came from the mountains as well they
want the artificial limbs
shazia is trying out her new prosthetic
leg
her uncle is nearby in case she falls
she says she wore her favorite dress to
mark the day when she walked again
she was four years old when an explosive
tore off her leg
she had to stop going to school but now
she says she wants to go back
and one day be a doctor
i used to see other children walk to
school every day but i couldn't go with
them
i would see them playing but i couldn't
join i'm very fond of learning but i had
to stop my studies
but now i can go back to school i can
walk again
the path ahead may still be challenging
but people here say they now look
forward to walking through it
on their own katya lopezodayan
al jazeera